please welcome Robert Lance
what was the Sweden to Stockholm thank
you I hadn't been here for I think two
two-and-a-half years yeah you actually
recorded an album here once apparently
it is a funny show isn't it I used to
catch the bus to polar studios on a
morning with the bass player John Paul
Jones from Led Zeppelin we used to go to
pull us studios the home of Benny and
beyond it was an experiment and it was
an experiment in as much as we were
contacted by your Swedish luminaries and
they said would Led Zeppelin like to
come and record free of charge now we'd
like to look after our money with our
investments in pharmaceuticals we had so
he's a catch the bus would go to polish
studios that in Devon and we recorded
our very last studio album there yeah
did you get to know been embarrassed um
at night time yeah at night I'm mostly
night time so you were out on well we
didn't know our way around the
demi-monde
of the town so we pressed Benny and
Bjorn into taking us out and about his
yeah they were very hospitable showed us
must show to Stockholm really yeah the
sort of pop gods meets the the rock gods
it's it's incredible you know it's well
we were just all gods said there was no
differentiation really about me at all
and look where we end up
you know pause me not at all yeah you
still have contact with any of them
but Benny's coming to our show tonight
we're playing oh yeah her next so we've
been talking about Tori and I I want and
also to tour in different cultures with
your touring experience I wonder how
however you experience the different
cultures I did play some peculiar places
I played in Hong Kong after Led Zep in
the early eighties and I played at the
gig and they hadn't had many gigs in so
the culture was to embrace western music
but people didn't really have a clue of
how to respond to it
so I played this loud music and did a
lot of preening and the audience was
full of boys because it was supposed to
be rocks and therefore there'd be no
girls and the boys had heard that had
shows you scream so I was singing to
three thousand screaming boys which well
I didn't tell anybody else to Eton's but
it's just boys instead yeah yeah yeah it
was a bit tough yeah there were lots of
very very interesting and peculiar and
each country has its own way like once
upon a time up here in and further up
and further down the Scandinavians took
to the weed so the would be it would be
very difficult to applaud when everybody
was particularly stoned so there's a
great thing from either whether it's
Danish TV or whatever of Led Zeppelin
black and white and people are trying to
clap along their completely missing
their hands it's a bit like that film
the jerk you know it I can't quite get
there and that that conditions may have
moved down to Holland where it's going
along very nicely in Switzerland once we
played I played in a field full of mud
and with string sting and the
and and everybody they like you they go
whoo
so you got 25,000 people covered in mud
which is a market term of endearment you
know I was like it was a very nice thing
today you've been touring a lot I met
touring now with my show around Norway
but as I told you I bring my wife with
me my my wife says if you go on your own
you either get divorced or you become an
alcoholic so she followed me that's the
most safe thing to do she says I'm
divorced
because of the touring because I got
lucky I think I mean it was only 28
years ago that's our space it's time to
change spots is it is it is it a big
difference between touring before
entering today well I never had an
afternoon nap until recently yeah I
don't look as good as this always you
know I just been sleeping in the
darkroom yeah I was awake a lot longer
in the old days you know I was very
stimulated but perhaps but yeah I mean
it's much better now in truth I mean it
was chaos then nobody there was no book
there's no handbook there was nobody
knew what was going on you didn't know
where you were always supposed to be or
where you'd been when you got home you
couldn't remember what you'd done tell
anybody what it was like and they gave
you some money but you probably spent
that before you got back so so you can't
actually remember throwing those
televisions out of the hotel window I
think that was Leonard Cohen
oh I don't know it was nothing to do
with us we've got everything that way
wrong was blamed on us because we never
did any press it's it's it's been said
that you had more sophisticated groupies
oh who said that I read it some
journalists say huh well I suppose there
were one or two girls who were excellent
with gymnastics and handicraft and
pharmaceuticals there was a lot
gardening's are very strong there was a
magazine in the 50s called health and
efficiency it always had some girls on
the beach throwing a beach ball we got
their moms you know you're here tonight
with a band of joy which is a very
critically acclaimed project and you
always seem to move on because the last
thing you did was with Alison Krauss and
and you got five Grammys for that album
but then you don't want to copy yourself
I don't know why I don't do that because
you could really you have a lot of
things you could now do again and yeah
you don't have to I mean why invent
something new well I'm not inventing it
I worked for a year with Alison and
alongside buddy who's my co-pilot in
this project and every night we used to
talk about American music and how
magnificent it is being British you know
we in the British music scene forever as
always looked West to America for its
inspiration you know or now into North
Africa quite a lot you know and so being
around Bode Miller was something real
special and we talked about music talked
about it and then when the time came to
work we had the opportunity to get
together and but he brought along Patty
Griffin and you know Daryl Scott and
it's good fun it's very young it's in
its embryonic stages and we laugh a lot
and Patti laughs at me a lot because
with the Led Zeppelin songs although we
modify them if I go into character a
little bit she thinks it's very funny
and I can't keep a straight face you
know and the audience thinks it's great
I'm going ah we got that old joke again
when is a door not a door when it's ajar
you know but hahaha how do you react
when you if you stand in an elevator and
you hear a versatile stairway to heaven
well does the turn into an elevator to
hell for you or no no I mean something
happens everyday you know I mean that
song was written one day and and it has
a kind of piety which was appropriate at
the time but you know now the twangs of
thank you know those days with those
days and and however you when you write
songs you can if you write them in the
abstract they work for a period of time
and then after that you see right the
way through to the next part of your
life inshallah inshallah I don't know
how you would say it but but what is how
does one not age with dignity in this
business I suppose you think a lot about
that I think you're just got to do what
you're comfortable with and down once
upon a time I was in the kitchen all the
time and now I put my shirt on and I'm
you know I'm waiting to be taken out for
a walk and I must say you have changed
rock'n'roll you have changed the face of
rock n roll you have been a huge
inspiration and to a lot of brilliant
musicians but also to a lot of
fair-haired singers how does that feel
do you like all of them well yeah I
think that you know the guys in Led
Zeppelin were spectacular players and
you know we lost John but Jimmy and John
Paul are still magnificent and really it
was in a Serendip it was a amazing
phenomena that we got together and did
what we did honestly for honesty's sake
not for money or for kudos but and then
we got into that whole deal you know the
fair-haired singers well I'm in the land
of fair-haired singers now untie you
everywhere there's one or two nice ones
around but they're not male
thank you so much Judy a treasure
welcome to to Stockholm your your your
sound expert and you're also the author
of the book sound business yes and first
of all it's much